while there it's true that there's
deterioration in response
oh that doesn't mean you can't have good
sexual experiences I I play a little bit
of tennis but there's not a joint in my
body that doesn't ache when I play um if
I could go back in a time machine
I could I could beat the 25 year old me
who was half my age at tennis yet that
man would be stronger than I am he'd be
able to run faster he gets the ball more
quickly he'd hit it much harder but I
would be able to win a match because I
would play more strategically that this
25 years of additional experience would
help me keep my emotions in check keep
my focus and basically have this poor
kid running back and forth to the net
and eventually losing in the same way
people through good communication and
technique and loving relationships
continue can continue to have a great
sex life all their life as long as
they're physically had
I think if we go back to when I first
started I'm doing this kind of work
which is question you asked me one of
the most common problems have had time
was women having an inability to reach
orgasm and that's something that's
really changed dramatically over a
generation where many women have learned
to self stimulate so that they
understand a little more what goes on in
their bodies so one of the major changes
that's taken place statistically and
early in the last 2530 years is that
women have learned how to self stimulate
in the same way that most boys always
knew and did and they've learned about
their own bodies that allows many women
to be more naturally responsive when
they're with a partner and if he's a
little clumsy to be able to give him
some guidance as to what will help make
things work better so in general women
have caught up a lot with men where I
think things are lacking is science
because it's been male-dominated has
focused more on helping them than
helping women and many of us are trying
to change that so there's a couple areas
that are being looked upon on number one
is hormonal e we know that testosterone
is a hormone of desire in both men and
women women have less of it than men do
so how might we be able to provide women
who are low in testosterone and needing
testosterone that hormone without
putting them at risk for other diseases
which we know can come from messing
around with people's hormones so there's
concern about the consequences of that
but there's tremendous amount of
research going on right now to
investigate it and many physicians are
carefully using these drugs on an
off-label basis quite effectively with
their patients so that's on a hormonal
level on the level of blood flow just
like men the vagina engorges with blood
that causes an internal sweating
response which is lubrication the
clitoris swells and her body becomes
more physically sensitive now in 35
years of practice no woman has ever come
to see me saying you know my clitoris
isn't big enough is there something you
can do
that so it's not that these drugs will
make somebody's clique so much bigger
and that that would be a big deal that's
not the situation but are there drugs
that might help overcome a woman
suffering from vaginal dryness because
of a disease process where these could
be used in conjunction with counseling
for both her and her partner to help her
be able to be more responsive and that
would be very important and then going
back to our earlier discussion of drugs
that effect desire an arousal at a
central level in the brain this is a
critical area of research right now for
five or six different pharmaceutical
companies worldwide looking into how can
in particular the dopamine system which
is one of the neurotransmitters in the
brain be used to help facilitate sex
without having any negative consequences
physiologically to the rest of the body
one way of understanding this in fact is
many of the drugs that people would be
familiar with that are commonly used by
psychiatrists to treat depression SSRIs
which are prozac Zoloft these types of
drugs have an impact on serotonin so by
elevating serotonin and neurotransmitter
in the brain something that helps
signals move more rapidly and
effectively in the brain elevating that
elevates mood so for some people these
antidepressants actually are helpful
sexually but for many people elevating
serotonin actually makes it more
difficult to reach orgasm and diminishes
our desire
so the serotonergic system can act as a
sort of stop on sex and inhibit or go
back to the sexual tipping point model
that pharmaceutical can kind of depress
a sexual response and indeed many of
people in my field physicians will use
that as an off-label treatment for
premature ejaculation I say off-label
because it's not approved by the FDA for
use in that light however many
physicians because these drugs are
legally available will instruct the
patient how they may use this to slow
down their ejaculatory reflex what does
this have to do with women lots of women
for better for
really obviously for worse our our
stressed out and for better these drugs
do help the mood for some people but
some of these women who are on
antidepressants which are somewhat
ubiquitous and perhaps even overused in
our society are suffering from the
negative side effects of these drugs and
while they feel a little bit better and
they're a little less stressed their
sexual response has been diminished so
if there was something that could be
used that would improve mood without
negatively affecting sexual function
that would be great and that has to do
with it probably the dopaminergic system
dopamine is a transmitter oxytocin is
another hormone that functions in
similar ways and these are the things
that are under investigation right now
which is really what's going to be
coming out
I think the most important thing that I
could tell men about female sexuality it
has to do more with female self-esteem
in our society which is under continuous
assault by all the advertising that's
going on and there's been you know
thousands and thousands of documents
written about this and programs produced
about this you know we have a society
that overemphasizes of physical
attributes so anything you can do to
help her feel pretty and sexy and
appreciated will go a long long way
towards improving your sexual connection
because that's gonna make her feel good
and if she feels good she's going to be
more receptive to sexual experience
and she's